anything it's nice to see a nice crowd
here tonight I remember thank you I
remember when I first thought about
doing something on this assassination
somebody told me well you better get it
out real quick because a year to the
Kennedy assassination is going to be a
dead subject well I don't think anything
is farther from the truth
it's just like she said it's like the
Civil War it seems to be weather seems
to be hanging on now on my background I
was a FBI agent for 27 years and I
retired at age 55 which is a mandatory
retirement age for FBI agents I was the
I was the third of three agents to have
the Lee Oswald case assigned as you
probably know he defected to the Soviet
Union spent three years and then when he
returned he was interrogated twice by
the first agent that had the case he
then went to New Orleans where he was
interrogated again and finally where I
got into the case was when he contacted
the Soviet embassy in mexico city under
surreptitious circumstances and less
than 30 days before the assassination I
was given the assignment to look into
that and discreetly determine what was
amiss now I was the first FBI agent to
interrogate Oswald after he was arrested
I was up there at the police department
and started interviewing him within an
hour after his apprehension I was also
the first one to interview marine Oswald
after the assassination I had
interviewed her shortly before the
assassination also as you will see she
was also somewhat suspect a lot of
people don't realize that I also
interrogate the Paynes Ruth and Michael
Payne who were very much involved in
this thing so I was involved in
much of the investigation post
assassination as well as pre
assassination now people ask me why am i
doing it now why have I waited 32 years
well as the lady said they introduced me
a lot of this material was classified
top secret up until recently I of course
had signed the secrecy agreement and
could not talk about many of these
things and of course many of the things
as you'll see for me in the book I
didn't know after the assassination
occurred there was a sort of a little
bit of a cover-up I guess you could say
and they were covering up from me as
much as anybody they didn't want me to
know how headquarters had fouled up so
to speak so I gradually found things out
over a period of time I found out quite
a bit in 1976 when I testified before
the Senate Intelligence Committee the
Church Committee and then of course as
the various things were bring relief
from the archives now the because of the
movie JFK or what I call the monstrosity
JFK Congress decided well enough is too
much we're going to tell the public what
really happened and so they passed the
JFK Disclosure Act there is a board of
five eminent scholars who are going over
all of the things in the archives that
are classified top secret secret and so
forth and are winning it out and
releasing nearly all of it now I
understand the only thing that they're
not going to release if there is an
informant who is still alive or still
viable in some way they will not
disclose that person's name for their
own safety
and they're not going to disclose
investigative techniques that are not
known to the public for obvious reasons
they might want to be able to use them
again
now another reason why I finally wrote
the book is from because of my family as
any of you of know a lot of you have
done research on this you'll know that
my name has appeared in many of these
books and I could say
really kind of tough III sort of feel
like a man who's been bound and gagged
and being pecked to death by a bunch of
chickens
that's about the way I feel about a lot
of these books but my family wanted me
to set the record straight I'm 71 now
two years ago and I 69 my younger son
came to me and said we've got to put
this down and writing if nothing for
nothing more than just for your
grandchildren and your great
grandchildren so for this reason I I sat
down with my youngest son who's an
attorney he was by co-author he has a
journalism degree that was his
undergraduate degree and he he helped me
put this thing together as Tom said my
son Tom said he said he wanted to have
this written for his grandchildren
well now Tom's oldest son was only 5
years old and he's worried about
grandchildren already that shows us so
because I say because of all of the the
false information being put out and fact
the government is now trying to
straighten it out we're now trying to
get this thing squared away now the
questions that people mostly asked was
did I as well do it and did he do it
alone based upon the information I have
the evidence that I have I would say yes
he did do it did he act alone again
based upon the information I have and
the evidence I have I'll have to say
that he did act alone was there a
cover-up yes
not only a cover-up I think there was at
least two cover-ups after the fact first
by the United States government what I
call a benign and coverup them
Lyndon Johnson decided in 1963 when he
saw what the situation was that if the
American public was told the entire
truth about Oswald and particularly his
contacts in Mexico City shortly before
the assassination this could have led to
World War three and you all know from
your history that
World War 1 began almost exactly the
same way the crown prince of Austria was
assassinated by a bust me and serb we're
still having trouble at the Boston Ian
service by the way in Sarajevo and they
went after Serbia and then Russia came
to Serbia as defense and then one thing
led to another we had World War one
Johnson was fearful of this so he with
the unanimous consent of the National
Security Council which included the
president's brother Robert Kennedy
agreed that the whole story would not be
told just recently President Ford the
sole surviving member of the Warren
Commission and the magazine article
appeared in American heritage November
1995 issue stated concerning the Warren
Commission we told the truth we just
didn't tell the whole truth now
I also feel that it's very possible in
fact based upon me some of these
documents have been released now that
there was also a cover-up on the part of
the Soviet Union Castro and the American
Communist Party I'll give you an example
document has just been released that
showed that Gus fall the leader of the
American Communist Party approached
fortunately one of our informants who
was a go-between between the Communist
Party in the Soviet Union and asked the
Soviet Union to contact marine Oswald
who was then under interrogation by the
FBI and try to tell her to tell us that
her husband was really a right-wing
conspirator that he was working with the
Minuteman to throw us off the Soviet
Union said that's impractical we're not
going to do it but that is an example of
how they were trying to cover up of the
first seven authors that wrote books
about the assassination on which a lot
of the research has since developed you
know one researcher goes to another
researcher and they build on each other
six out of the first seven
researchers had communist backgrounds
and were putting out the Soviet line
there that house wall either didn't do
it or if he did do it he was connected
to the right they'll give you an example
now they say that when you write a story
and journalists are told there's five
W's who what when where and why the
Warren Commission accurately reported
first of the four why's they did tell us
who where when but they did not tell us
why because if they had it could have
possibly led to World War three now let
me explain what I mean is you all know
particularly down here in Miami there's
probably some people here of Cuban
extraction and I don't have to tell you
about the Bay of Pigs on which was an
unfortunate situation that unfortunately
Castro had penetrated the the invasion
and I was able to thwart it then we had
the Cuban Missile Crisis a year later
now I can tell you this from what I know
from being in the FBI we were very very
close to World War three during the
Cuban Missile Crisis we were within a
day a day and a half of possibly
invading Cuba at that time when Castro
backed out mean when Khrushchev back
down Castro did not back down at that
point Kennedy started to get along with
Khrushchev after the Cuban Missile
Crisis and we first had the first test
ban treaty which followed that the
summer of 63 the first sale of wheat and
the first exchange of scholars and so
forth Castille them as now refused to
cooperate he refused to go long he was
furious with the Russians for backing
down during the Cuban Missile Crisis so
on June the 19th 1963 two days after
Kennedy began his overtures towards the
Soviet Union he ordered the CIA to go
after Castro again the 64 election was
coming up and he wanted Castro gone by
the 64 election Barry Goldwater was
going to use it against him and he knew
it the CIA made contact was one of
Castro's cabinet officers one rolando
who Bela we've got a picture of Rolando
Cabella in the book here we go into all
this Cabella was a leader of the urban
guerillas when Castro was a leader of
the guerrillas in the hills Cabella was
a leader of the urban guerrillas and was
a revolutionary hero in his own right he
could have just as easily taken over
rather than Castro so he was heard of a
rival to Castro and was very upset about
the fact that Castro would let the
Russians into Cuba so they were dealing
with an lash and that was his code name
M lash was a code name for Cabella they
were dealing with him hoping to work out
a deal where they could overthrow Castro
get rid of the Russians and work things
out I don't know what what they had in
mind but Castro found out about this in
on September the 7th 1963 he approached
a Canadian Associated Press reporter
named Daniel Harker and told him in
effect I'm paraphrasing now that we know
the American leaders are trying to
overthrow the Cuban leaders and they may
find out that two people can play this
game
now I'm paraphrasing it but it was a
definite threat saying we know what
you're up to and I'm will retaliate in
kind not all newspapers carried this
article Washington Post New York Times
we're trying to get Kennedy to kiss and
make up at Castro and they thought it
was provocative so they left it out the
two papers in Dallas will turn up
portray Kennedy as a wimp on Castro they
were Pro Goldwater so they didn't print
it but both New Orleans newspapers did
print it and that's where as well was at
the time
six days after this article appeared
I've wall made arrangements to go to
Mexico City one in Mexico City he met
with the Cubans and what the Soviets he
met with the head of the KGB
assassination a Colonel Vivi caustic off
whose picture I also have in here
he was the western hemisphere chief in
charge of all assassinations kidnapping
and sabotage for the KGB
Oswald also met with the Cubans and we
know from a top-level informant I have
the communication in here in in the
archives this is something we couldn't
talk about until recently but Oswald in
talking to the Cubans according to
Castro himself said I'm paraphrasing
again quote that son-of-a-bitch Kennedy
I think I'll kill him now
if the Cubans said no don't dare do that
then they would not be of course
involved if they said yes go ahead and
do it then we have a conspiracy Maul
likelihood what they said was probably
nothing just laughed it off think he
thinking he was just popping off people
do a lot of popping off but then what's
what does he do he goes back to Dallas
and does exactly what he said so was
there a conspiracy the definition of the
conspiracy is two more persons agree
together to commit an illegal act and
one or more of those persons begins to
carry it out so if the Cubans that in
any way encouraged Oswald to do it then
you could say there's a conspiracy but
we can't prove that they say that they
didn't tell him to do it they said he
was just popping off and they didn't
tell him one way the other so that is
what Johnson was facing in 1963 and this
is what he did not want the American
public to know I heard from sources of
myung down in Mexico City that the CIA
agents in Mexico City
furious when President Johnson ordered
them to cease their investigation they
had come up with some very good leads
which were tending to implicate the
Cubans for example they were able to
pick up apparently on a tech or a tap of
some sort
one louisa called drone a Cuban
intelligence agent when told that
President Kennedy had just been killed
she laughed and said we knew it was
going to happen now what that meant we
don't know Castro will not let anybody
talk to her with a house assassination
committee went and talked to several
Cuban and she was the one person he
wouldn't let us talk to so then there
was also the case of the airplane which
I'm going to mention in here you can
read the book and see the different
things that that sort of tended to
indicate the possibility of possible
Cuban involvement now at this point we
don't have enough evidence if the
investigation works out if there might
be in other words we don't have proof
but we do have an incomplete
investigation if the income of the
investigation were ever completed it
would probably answer the questions I'm
inclined to think personally that the
Cubans did not tell him to do it
they didn't take him seriously and he
went back and did it that's what I'm
trying to think but I until such time as
we find out what Luisa Calderon was
talking about and who the mysterious
person who flew down Mexico City was we
can't really say now in the book I go
into such things as the Secret Service
protection I'm not blaming a Secret
Service it wasn't their fault they only
had 300 men in the entire United States
to handle counterfeiting check forgery
and protecting the president they were
undermanned understaffed because of
inner service rivalry and pride they
would not ask
the other federal agencies to help them
a lot of people think that everybody in
the federal government pitched in and
helped well the Secret Service didn't
want us helping him therefore the
president was inadequately guarded the
main reason he was inadequately guarded
that day was because President himself
told the Secret Service that they could
not ride on the car where he was I
happened to see the motorcade go by the
car the President Kennedy was in was
totally unprotected there was nobody
under running boards there were no
motorcycles alongside as you probably
know some of you have seen as a pruder
film The Secret Service guards were one
car back they should have been on
Kennedy's car that's where they want it
to be the motorcycle should have been
alongside of Kennedy but he wanted this
was a political trip he wanted to show
everybody he was going into enemy
territory Dallas was very anti Kennedy
and he was gonna go in and show them he
wasn't afraid he was gonna pull a John
Wayne and go in there and show them that
he wasn't afraid and therefore he had no
protection had the guards been where
they wanted to be on the running boards
the guard and the right rear would have
blocked Oswald's line of fire and
probably taken the shot or certainly
been able to react quicker did you
remember from the Sapru der film Clint
Hill jumped off the car behind and ran
flat-out
as fast as he could he just barely got
on the car they were just too far back
Kenny O'Donnell who was a chief of staff
for President Kennedy after the
assassination talking about the
protection said we had our choice
between security and politics we chose
politics in other words it's not the
fault of the Secret Service as I said
that climate in Dallas was very hostile
to Kennedy and that's why he was going
in there to try to shore up Texas he
just barely carried Texas in the 1960
election and he knew he was going to
face a tough fight with Barry Goldwater
particularly in Texas he'd lost
Dallas two-to-one and he was trying to
cut that down try to make it a little
bit more even and that was the reason he
went there now in the book I'm also
talking about marina as well now
everybody has seen the picture of her
the poor bereaved Widow carrying a child
right after Oswald was killed and
everybody took her to heart and they say
a picture is worth ten thousand words
who marina as you'll see in the book
it's got a interesting background she
isn't at all the sweet shy little
peasant girl people think she is we
found out after the assassination she
was raised by her uncle she was an
orphan she was raised by her mother's
brother who just happened to be a
colonel in the Russian MVD now the MVD
is not the KGB the MVD is part of the
police apparatus he was in what they
call gulag the prison officials he was a
high-ranking prison official she lived
in the building with him in which all of
the people in there were either
high-ranking MVD or KGB agents so she
was also a member of the Communist Party
as we know also in here I go into Jack
Ruby
everybody thinks Jack Ruby had a bit in
the mob this had have been a hit well I
can show you in black and white how it's
virtually impossible that he was sent in
to kill to kill Oswald that we can show
that four minutes before he killed
Oswald he was next door setting a
telegram
Oswald was supposed to moved an hour and
a half earlier and I go into all of that
also we had pretty good book on me on
who the mob was and who they weren't you
know starting at fifty nine after the
Appalachian meeting there was an
intensive investigation of who was in
the mob and we know that Ruby definitely
because of the nature of his business
had contact with these people but he was
also in contact with the Dallas police
and with the FBI he was an informant for
both the police and the FBI
by the way that that's how the false
rumor got started that Oswald was an
informant it was Ruby who is the
informant and somebody overheard a
conversation got it mixed up I've got
that all in the book too but we know
that ruby was not in the mob he did have
contacts but stop and reason what good
would it do to send Ruby in to kill
Kennedy I mean to kill Oswald and then
they would have Ruby and he could lead
them back to the conspirators you don't
you're jumping out of the frying pan
into fire when you do this besides this
Ruby was in the police station all
weekend there's pictures of him is as
close to Oswald oh that cameraman is
there in the back and he he had his
pistol then he could have rushed up and
shot Oswald Friday night and silence
them 48 hours earlier so it just doesn't
make sense I also have in the book I
didn't go into the evidence too much as
I pointed out there's other people have
done books forensic scientists and so
forth about why Kennedy was killed by Oz
well you know the direction of the shots
and all that kind of thing I did add a
chapter however and some of the things
that I have about the so called magic
bullet
now the magic bullet wasn't as magic as
people say it is like they like to show
you the people like oh I forget who some
of these people are but they will show
you the magic bullet and I'll show you
say look it's pristine the nose is not
bent at all it's not knocked at all but
what they don't do is they don't turn it
over and show you the back side of the
bolt the back side of the bullet is
flattened out and distended what
happened when Kennedy was hit it went
through his neck came up through his tie
we know that because there's a hole in
his tie knot with the threads thrust
outward it came out it hit Connally in
the back but when it hit Connally it was
turning over
Conley's wound was oblong that meant the
bullet went into Connally sideways and
continued to turn over and when it
finally hit comley's wrist
it was completely turned over and hit
his wrist backside first and that's the
part that's flattened now there is lead
this was a copper-jacketed ledcor bullet
there is no lead showing on the nose but
there is some of the lead missing from
the rear end of the bullet they have
been able to check to a 95% certainty
that the lead found and Conley's wrist
lead fragments match up to the lead and
that bullet also they they talked about
the head snap well the head snap was
caused by the jet effect of Kennedy's
skull exploding there's a hole in the
back of Kennedy's head by the scalp came
out through here his head was sort of
turned over a little bit because he'd
been hit once and he was turned over
like this it went through here and it
came out to the front and blew out the
front right part of his his skull when
it did that it was like a explosion a
jet effect and that is what threw his
head back you can do this experiment
with a melon put it on a post
shoot shoot a bullet to it and there'll
be a small hole in the front of the bull
of the melon the back end of the melon
will blow off and then the melon will
fly back towards the shooter caused by
the jet effect this is what happened
also I remember in the movie JFK they
try to reenact and say how they didn't
line up for Connolly and oz and Kennedy
be hit by the same shot well what they
did is they had Kennedy and Connally
sitting on chairs directly one right
behind the other and on the same level
actually Kennedy was about four inches
to the right and about four inches
higher in the jump seat when the first
shot was fired which missed Kennedy
ducked what happens when you do that you
ticked Connally and turn him around if
Kennedy ducking have Kennedy to the
right and higher
it lines up perfectly this has been
demonstrated I've seen demonstrations
with dummies and that's how it works out
now that pretty well completes what I've
got to say I didn't I don't want to tell
you about the whole book as I say I've
got documents in here that have just
been released including the document
where a top-level FBI undercover man met
with Castro himself and Castro himself
told us that Oswald threatened to kill
Kennedy we've got that we've got
pictures of caustic off the KGB
assassination expert and of AM lash the
High Cuban official that the CIA was
dealing with by the way M lash was
arrested by Castro after the
assassination you waited 2-3 years sort
of played the string along so to speak
we think he was double that M lash was
doubled as they say he was told he
cooperated with us I will kill you right
now he was put on trial and found guilty
of trying to assassinate Castro now can
you imagine this he was then pardoned by
Castro Castro shoots people for just
black market but here's a man that
confessed a lot in the kill Castro and
he pardons them now what happens after
the house assassination committee
completed their report what happened
Castro releases him he's now out now you
tell me that's not a double agent
operation but that'll conclude what I
have to say and as I say you can read
the book most of it goes into how I was
doing the investigation and how I found
out about these things as we went along
now do we have any questions yes and
back
he said that he was angry he said he was
Pro Kennedy which I think that was
pretty well proven also Oswald had also
killed officer Tippit the police officer
who Ruby knew ruby is a good friend of
the police
he said that when Oswald came out of the
jail
elevator that morning there were bright
lights on similar what we have back here
and Oswald had a smart alecky smirk on
his face he said that just set him off
he was mad at him as it was you know if
you're Pro Kennedy you'd be pretty mad
at him and he said that he wanted to the
statements he made was he wanted to show
the world that the Jews got guts and he
didn't want Jackie Kennedy to have to
come down to testify and he said you
cops couldn't do this but I can do it I
mean it was a combination of he wanted
revenge and he thought he'd win a place
in history I'll give you an example the
man who killed John Wilkes Booth's that
John Wilson was arrested then killed by
one of the guards do you know what
happened to that guard he became a hero
they made him sergeant-at-arms in the
Kansas State Legislature for life this
Ruby thought he'd be a hero do something
that nobody else could do said he was
just gonna be the executioner yes sir
you mentioned in in the book on page 96
I believe it is that you felt frustrated
in the early stages of the investigation
because he felt as if everything you
were doing was being scrutinized and
nitpicked right even though you had been
acting by the book I believe as Harris
write it maybe I'm missing something but
it doesn't seem quite by the book to
tear up a note from the assassin and
flush it down the toilet that's true
however I was told to do that I was
following orders
that's true but the people who were
nitpicking me were the ones that ordered
ordered me to do it so I don't feel that
that they should have been
second-guessing me on that point
then didn't you wonder that maybe you
shouldn't do that then why they were
ordering you to commit a crime basically
well as it turned out it wasn't a crime
as I point out in the book there it
turns out that since Oswald was dead
and there could be no trial and since it
never been entered into the record
and of course I wish I hadn't have done
it I'll tell you that right now because
all of this conjecture about all the
false reasons as to why it was done it
was definitely not anything more than
just a a complaint about me interviewing
his wife but you'd have to understand
Jed Gerber
he had a hellacious temper now I can
explain this to anybody who's ever in
the FBI and he understand immediately
they say the old man would have blown up
and in order to keep him from blowing up
they just decided just we just won't
tell him he was sort of like the Emperor
and the Emperor's clothes you know they
would not tell they tell him what he
wanted to hear and not and keep bad
things from him at the time the nut was
destroyed Johnson was saying there was
going to be no hearings we're not gonna
do see he was worried to death about
World War three said we're not gonna
have any hearings just report back to me
and this were in other words the word
was out there was going to be a cover-up
so I guess the FBI officials and and the
CIA and everybody else figured well
we'll have our little secondary
cover-ups the primary cover-up was the
was what happened in Mexico City and
then the CIA covered up the fact that
they were dealing with want to Castro's
cabinet officers to try to assassinate
him they covered that up and I guess
then the FBI covered up I don't know
what all the Secret Service in the State
Department covered up but yeah that
that's true I shouldn't have done it I
admit it and I wished I hadn't but
you've got to remember we were all in a
state of shock I think I was in more
shock over Oswald being killed by Ruby
and I was by Kennedy being killed I
I have an heir that we had received
information